[Music]
and now deep tweets
by Matt Walsh
[Music]
earlier I tweeted that emojis are for
children and women and that grown adult
men shouldn't use them I'm trending on
Twitter now because many people are
rightly angry about it I apologize
I should have mentioned that emojis are
also for illiterates forgive my
oversight
my seven-year-old pangender child
Sundance just came right up to me and
asked Matt what happens if there's
another January 6th can our democracy
survive
I looked them right in the eyes and said
my child it's already dead
we just held each other and sobbed
[Music]
my pronouns are me and myself when you
refer to me you must say me which means
you'll be talking about yourself because
I identify as you and also me I identify
as everyone your identity has been
collapsed into mine you must respect
this or else you are transphobic
foreign
Drew in red marker all over his face
then got scared that we'd be mad so we
tried to hide it by wrapping toilet
paper around his head like a mummy then
he promptly ran into a wall and nearly
knocked himself unconscious
update I'm told that his sister came up
with a toilet paper solution now it's
all starting to make sense
update I dropped a very clever you must
be red in the face about this joke but
no one left
foreign
I would like to sincerely apologize for
the Reckless comments that got me
suspended I now realize that biology
doesn't exist science is a myth men are
women women are men penises are vaginas
and vaginas are penises it all makes
sense to me now I regret the error
[Music]
parenting young children is just
shouting where are your shoes over and
over again into a void until the words
seem to lose all meaning
foreign
the government literally admitted that
we're being invaded by space aliens
today and you people don't even care
well they may not have admitted it
exactly but I choose to interpret the
events in this way and live my truth
announcement I Didn't Do It for the
accolades but if anyone does want to
nominate me for a Nobel Peace Prize in
recognition of my philanthropic
Endeavors I will not turn down the award
foreign
look sometimes kids grab steak knives
and stab other kids in the driveway
we've all been there just innocent kid
stuff can't believe the cops had to get
involved at all let kids be kids
[Music]
my son told me that a kid was teasing
him by rhyming his name in insulting
ways I asked him the other kid's name
and gave him some ideas for Rhymes he
can use against him my wife does not
agree with my parenting strategy but I
feel that name rhyming and self-defense
is ethical
foreign